Cuál es el llamado que hacen desde las
filas de su partido a los ciudadanos
peruanos que
comparten con ustedes esta impresión de
una detención ilegal del expresidente
Castillo
Muchas gracias y buenas tardes estimado
Santiago por la posibilidad de
dirigirnos y explicar un poco la
situación acá en el Perú
diecisiete meses de enfrentamiento en el
poder
diecisiete meses sin tregua
haciendo del desprecio político como si
fuera forma de hacer política como
obstruccionismo parlamentario intento de
vacancia una vez dos veces censuras se
alteró el equilibrio de poderes aquí
regulando la cuestión de confianza
favoreciendo al congreso en esa
prerrogativa justamente
ese enfrentamiento por el poder motivó
Decisiones extremas no solamente si
respeto al debido proceso por la
vacancia Exprés del presidente Pedro
Castillo terrones su prisión preventiva
es decir hoy la gente las calles las
regiones del Perú protestan justamente
por esta forma tan subjetiva se llama un
momento golpista de haber resuelto aquí
la situación de la democracia en el Perú
la gente sale justamente a protestar la
salida y renuncia de este gobierno que
se era ilegítimo la gente pide un
gobierno de transición la gente pide la
estabilidad democrática Paz social Pero
reclama con voz firme en todas las
regiones para una salida política
dialogada y que empiece en primer lugar
con la revisión de todo lo que ha
significado la cárcel preventiva al
presidente Pedro Castillo su vacancia
Express porque no se ha respetado el
mínimo estándar de la institucionalidad
del sistema interamericano en democracia
en el debido proceso y justicia en ese
clima nos encontramos con todo el Perú
con todo el sur fundamentalmente
retomando las protestas pacíficas desde
el día de hoy